foreign
to lose my five-year-old son a little
bit what is helping you arrive at that
conclusion 2019 killed just a couple
weeks ago I was in you know kind of an
office again on again Affair I would
throw everything to the wind I would
even kind of push him back
[Music]
what up what up what up this is John
with the Dr John deloney show so glad
that you joined us
taken the World by storm we're not
really but I am
happy to invite you to the greatest
mental health and marriage and parenting
education whatever podcast ever made
ever ever I declare it so
um hey if you want to help me out you
want to help the show out way more
important than me and the show
do you want to help out your neighbor
that friend from church your that Mom
that you met that dad that you work with
if you I want to introduce them to the
show send them a link to the show please
go review it five star reviews
um if you have a four or three star
review
just write that on a piece of toilet
paper and flush it
um hit the Subscribe button real low-fi
ways simple ways you can help us out
having to uh we don't have to ask you to
go buy something or something like that
um thank you so so so much for the
continued support if you want to be on
the show give me a buzz at
1-844-693-3291 this show is for you and
it's about you and it's by you so we
can't do it without you guys
thank you so much to those who write and
call in
1-844-693-3291 or go to John deloney.com
ask speaking of not asking you to buy
stuff Booyah by the way Booyah here's
the story on Booyah
um it was like when I was in Middle
School or high school that that came out
in some song it was absurd it was so
dumb and my friend buddy used to say
Booyah and then it became a funny way to
make fun of people who actually said it
for real and then here I am 25 years
later and I say it regularly and that's
a shameful moment in my in the John
Delaney history but here we are the new
second edition questions for humans
couples editions that's what I'm talking
about questions for human second edition
for friends you can go hang out go grab
some drinks and some chips and queso and
some nachos
it has some cards the second edition
questions for humans
parents and kids all new questions all
new topics all new rabbit holes to go
down with your friends and family and
we're gonna save your holiday this year
with the questions for humans Christmas
and New Year's you all know that I'm
obsessed with New Year's I love it that
we all just get a collective
um I didn't really like how I did that
this year and everyone's like cool just
do it over and we all just get a
mulligan every New Year's and so I love
New Year's and these are questions that
can help prompt you into the person
you're going to become in 2023
and
before I get to the first call can we
all disagree
whether it's wedding invitations as
you're starting to send out holiday
cards this year
birthday cards
stop
putting glitter in the envelopes
stop
stop listen there's enough Strife in the
world
the Russian invasion still going on
politics are everywhere I think right
when this podcast airs we're going to be
right there around the midterm elections
we don't need more trauma
and if I open up another envelope and
it's full of glitter and little little
cut hearts and
swords and whatever else people put
just a card just a card no Glitter or if
you want to be awesome
find that guy in college you didn't like
and fill an entire envelope full of
glitter and just put on the envelope
open as aggressively as possible that'd
be funny all right let's go to Rose in
Pullman Washington what's up Rose
hey thank you for taking my call you got
it near far I love that name do people
give you uh never mind all right okay
let's go let's go let's do this what's
up all right so a little bit of
background kind of just where I'm at I'm
a senior in college going to school
full-time
um I'm blessed to be on a sports
scholarship and an academic scholarship
so thanks to that and your guys's
program will be graduating in May debt
free wow very cool
and I'm also working part-time and I
know that I have a lesson year left and
in the whole scheme of life like the
eight next eight months is really short
but I'm exhausted yeah I was gonna say
do you sleep every other Saturday
I try to
what are you what are you studying
animal science
animal science what are you gonna be
when you grow up
um
um I have a focus in animal nutrition so
are you gonna go to vet school
no are you gonna work with like
gluten-free cows
yeah yeah
very cool when somebody brings their dog
in they're like we want to have a keto
dog you're like you came to the right
place yeah yeah no more not not pets so
what is that what does that animal
nutritionist do
um like design feed programs for cattle
operations pretty much
I thought
that rain fell and grass grew I thought
that was the feed operation so I'm glad
there are people like you out in the
world Rose making sure we have food to
eat because if it was up to me we would
all die that's fantastic okay so
um you're exhausted
and you got eight months till the finish
line and you and I both know that's not
how the world works because right when
you get to the Finish Line then you're
gonna have to have a job and move and
start a new job and life just goes crazy
ER
um so what are you gonna do
no I have as far as like after college
nope like for the next eight months
I don't know kind of keep my head down
and just get through it is the goal
that's the worst thing to do rose don't
just put your head down in a deal I'm
just kidding if that's what you got to
do if that's what you choose to do
um what what sports are you doing
I'm on the soccer team okay
and that season runs through the spring
huh
oh so you all haven't really started yet
have you
we have had a few games but it's not
full swing yet okay
here's what I've seen a million times
um
in the next month or two if you haven't
already you're gonna start thinking like
really kicking into gear about Life
After College
where am I going to live what's my job
going to be do you already have a job
lined up or have you started that
process yet
I've started
um
all right here's the deal we could if
you if you get to the finish line and
you collapse
you're gonna be no good to you you're
not going to be good to the new employer
that's going to pick you up you're not
going to be good to those animals that
you're serving Downstream you see what
I'm saying and so what we want to do is
to create a life worth living amidst the
chaos that is the last year of a
Collegiate athlete who's also working
part-time who's also filling the blank
filling the blank fill in the blank
Okay so
let's step all the way back on in order
of importance you got to graduate right
you got to make your grades and you're
on scholarships so you got to keep a
certain grade right
at this point in your career how hard is
that
it's getting harder to keep up with it
all okay
do you have to play sports I think it
was my junior year when I quit I was a
track athlete and I I quit I was doing a
lot of work to potentially run One race
in one event and yeah it just ultimately
I I quit
um do you have to keep playing
I don't have to you know
do you want to
um
I I do enjoy it and it is something that
I really connect with my parents over so
that's
worth what it is I guess
um but it's not worth your sanity it's
not worth your sanity
okay
what about this 20-hour week job
um
hopefully turn into
bigger job down the road so I'd like to
hang on to that
it might turn into a bigger job down the
road Maybe
and it might be just a great gig so
here's what I'm doing I'm I'm want to
look at all the things that take up your
time in your schedule
and I want to be really honest with
myself and say hey look I'm really
talented in a lot of things because you
are
and I can do a lot of things
for the next eight months for my senior
year in college what do I need to do to
be successful at the next stage
because the party life and the fun life
and the yeah traveling around like that
that part has to come to an end at some
point and you and I both know you've
probably got a couple of people who
graduated one or two years ago to still
hang around
yeah yeah because they can't let it go
and we also have people like me who
after their freshman sophomore year
they're like dude I was high school hero
it's time like I'm not gonna I'm not
going to the Olympics and I'm not that
I'm not going to do that well even in a
regular meet
um it's time
and
I don't know what that looks like for
you but here's what I'm telling you
something sounds like it's got to give
you sound exhausted
and if your body and mind aren't well
the rest of this stuff doesn't work all
right
um have you been struggling with
running low
or have you been more anxious than usual
okay has something else happened I
definitely felt like relationally
um
no not necessarily not
I mean there's always relational
struggles I feel like
a thing huge tell me if I'm off here
and I can be way off I'm throwing
something up against the wall here tell
me if I'm wrong
for a lot of the college athletes that
I've spent time with I was like I said I
was one but I spent a lot of time with
them over the years
and a lot of high performing students
who make great great great grades
the ones that were not going on to med
school or to law school or to some sort
of doctoral program
as they got to the end of their senior
year they had a crisis and here was the
crisis and you mentioned it
I am who I am because of the grades I
make and how I perform on an athletic
field
and the things that my parents have
drilled into me since I was four is
academic success and athletic
performance and achievement
and I'm getting your body knows that you
are about to run out of relational
capital
and it starts to Rattle the cage a bit
because we don't know who we are without
these two things and these two things
are eight months away and Ticking
yeah
and if I don't have sports
I don't know
it's it's kind of like whenever kids
leave and Mom and Dad
have looked at it to look at each other
like who are you
that's what your body sounds like it's
starting to feel
and there has been no preparation for
anything other than we're gonna make
good grades so that you can go get the
job of your dreams and make money or
whatever and you're going to do great on
the sports field because what because
it's so so fun for parents to tell their
friends that their kids are on a
scholarship
yeah you know what I mean
and I would love to hear I want to hear
you say and I'm not saying you do this
okay I just want you to practice this
pretend I'm your mom and dad
and tell me that you've chosen for the
last semester to not play soccer
hey
that that will be a hard conversation to
have no practice with me right now hey
Rose what's up what are you calling for
um I am not playing soccer next semester
it's gonna rip the Band-Aid off of that
one
yeah I hate you and I'm never coming
home bye right
um
is that a terrifying conversation or a
scary comment I mean what would the
response be back
supported the or supportive of it and I
feel like they'll also feel disappointed
maybe
where's that story coming from because I
don't know if that's true
um
this sports or soccer I think is
something like that we've connected over
like it's
my parents and so did not have that I'll
have to find something else here's
here's
um how old are you
I'm 22. okay you're 22.
I want you to practice the hardest adult
conversation you've probably had
and I want you to model it off what my
12 year old son did I think I've talked
about this on the show but when my 12
year old son did
um I think it was a year ago now
he knows that his dad is an obsessive
Houston Astros fan and we go to games
together we go to Minor League games
here in Nashville and we play catch and
he played baseball by baseball and
played baseball and he's actually pretty
good
and he called a family meeting and me
and my wife went into the meeting and we
were like wow I have a 12 year old
already calling family meetings this is
cool
it was not cool and he said
I don't want y'all to be disappointed
but
I would really like to not play baseball
this spring and instead I want to do
theater
and we're so I've never been more proud
of him
because I know how hard that was for him
and of course I was excited it was a
little bit weird right I had to mourn it
because I envisioned myself as a
baseball dad
and I don't give a crap you know how
much fun I had watching him at the play
it was the best watching him studies
lines and get all into character I loved
it loved it loved it loved it he just
got a part in this year's play uh
yesterday two days ago
so I would love you to model it like
this Rose I'd love you to call your
parents
or go see them in person and say I'm
scared to have this conversation because
I think you're going to be disappointed
in me
or I'm scared to have this conversation
because I don't think you'll be
disappointed but all we've ever
communicated really connected on is
soccer and for the last semester I've
got to focus on my grades and I've got
to focus on this internship and I got to
focus on my mental health because I'm
about to take the the biggest leap of my
life into the Working World
and I don't want to play soccer this
last semester and I'm worried you're
going to be disappointed in me I want
you to say it just like that adult to
adult to adult
I want you to go for it that way
and it may not be soccer it may be hey
I've got to drop this internship or hey
I can't come home over the break I'm
running too much too hot
um can I drop down to 15 hours but I'm
gonna need 200 a month or whatever
you're getting paid to help cover that
Gap but I can't go forward at this pace
at this schedule and be a good scholar
be a good student be a good the person I
want to be I can't be any of these
things if I've got this much crap going
on
okay
have this big hard hard
to child conversation it's going to be
one of the first ones if not the first
one that adjusts to adult
to adult
and let us know how this conversation
goes I'm proud of you Rose you're almost
there you're gonna make it we'll be
right back
it seems like everybody's talking about
how crazy the housing market is right
now and how powerless home buyers feel
mix that with the stress of moving and
life change and job change and you've
got a tornado of anxiety fueling one of
the biggest purchases you'll ever make
this is not a good idea so if you're a
new home buyer right now my advice to
you is to focus on what you can control
like the people you choose to help you
in the home buying process you need
folks like my friends at Churchill
Mortgage Churchill is a Ramsay trusted
provider that's been helping people with
their home mortgages for decades and
their home buyer Edge program will help
you skip a bunch of the stress here's
how it works apply to become a Churchill
certified home buyer and cap your
interest rate for 90 days then you'll
get a five thousand dollar seller
guarantee to help your offer stand out
so go ahead take a deep breath because
Churchill has your back check them out
at churchillmortgage.com deloney and get
the home buyer Edge today this is a paid
advertisement in MLS ID 1591 nmls
consumeraccess.org Equal Housing lender
1749 Mallory Lane Suite 100 Brentwood
Tennessee 37027 programs are for select
loan types only and not available in all
states or locations
all right we're back let's go to Joe in
Canada what up Joe
how's it going partying what are you
doing
I'm actually just
yes sir thanks for kicking us while
we're down appreciate that Joe real cool
I hope you have a 40 below winter in
Canada
so what's up
oh
um well first of all thanks for having
me on your show I appreciate it
absolutely thanks for calling in
and secondly I need your help on how I
deal with like conflict and I'll give
you a little background but that's kind
of the basis of it okay
um
so when I grew up my mom just recently
has been diagnosed kind of with
borderline personality disorder disorder
okay so I kind of diagnosed or all the
way diagnosed
um all the way diagnosed okay but it's
just very recent so it's still like in
process
um but so as a kid I kind of got a lot
of that the like brunt of
all of that and so I became a people
pleaser and just like terrified of
conflict since
I've kind of learned how to deal with it
with her but that also took almost
completely detaching myself emotionally
from her
um but then hang on one second for those
listening being the child of somebody
with borderline personality disorder is
uh frog's hair away of torture because
emotions are blow torches both the good
ones and the bad ones right
yeah and it is something that a
child cannot understand why mom is so
out of her mind angry over this and then
suddenly
she's laughing hysterically about a joke
that's not that funny and suddenly now
we're hugging and dancing and now we're
back to screaming like it is
trying to find equilibrium as a child is
it just it's everything's in chaos am I
onto it right Joe
yes yes okay
so yes often the only way a child can
survive that is to completely unplug
which is why you've got kids who are in
substance abuse or and really intense
romantic relationships very very early
um because they've got to detach from
the original power source here because
the power source is too unstable
Okay so
wow that sounds like my childhood yes
I feel like she hid it from me until I
was like a teen so it wasn't like
necessarily my childhood but yeah
definitely my like you know from 12 on
okay yeah
um but yeah so then fast forward to
about 20
17 2018.
um
my I
okay my husband is diagnosed with cancer
and probably like
2016. oh man and it was never gonna be
like a
they never thought it was a life or
anyone but anyway turns out two years
later they were very wrong and
[Music]
uh we at this time were living with my
in-laws which is not a great place to be
when you're going through hard times if
that relationship's already not you know
perfect
um and
my
way of dealing with with it was very
different and my and my way of dealing
with it
um which led to a lot of conflict and
at one point they asked me if I even
like cared about like him basically and
this is well I have two little girls and
so I was trying to live like a somewhat
normal life for them like I know nothing
was going to be normal but anyway this
was because I was going out for brunch
with my family as opposed to watching
hours of video on the treatment they
wanted to do which I was there to
support my husband I was like whatever
he wants to do oh Jojo I don't have the
energy
don't ever ever feel like you have to
defend that ever I know okay nonsense
Madness
um
no it wasn't because of that day that
day may have been the straw that broke
the Campbell's back but you lost your
mind because you had a really rough
childhood and then the man of your the
the guy you hit your wagon to next died
on you right
yeah yeah yes so he didn't die at this
point he was just in like very terminal
State at this time he was he was he was
dying on you right he was dying yeah
um but yeah so
there was just many times in like a six
week stand that things got super tense
between us and then after he actually
passed my in-laws
there was just like tension and it was
never really addressed it was just kind
of
oh enough time to stand by let's
hopefully everyone just forgot about it
and move on and now you're holding the
key to their magic little grandkids
exactly and those little grandkids are
there they have put all of their missing
love from their son into those little
two little girls to prop them up
yeah
and so I am just trying to understand
a I've moved away about a few months ago
just for a year for like I moved up to
uh please I'm from a different province
in Alberta and so I moved out to a place
that I could actually like rest for a
little bit and they came and visited
without giving me much
options as to say no that they couldn't
come at a certain weekend and it just
brought up so much anxiety and stress
for me that I honestly didn't think was
there okay and so I just it like brought
everything back of
how
hurt I was and how I just feel like
everything's just supposed to be
forgotten and even with how they showed
up there was never like an apology of
like oh I'm sorry we didn't take your
schedule into consideration it was just
like now oh well this is when it works
in in their defense
do they know this stuff
um what stuff
um I all I always give people a ton of
Grace
as they're dealing with the death of a
loved one
because everybody does that differently
and the old saying goes nobody makes
good decisions when they're scared or
when they're drunk
and there's a few things more terrifying
so
I absolutely think the way they treated
you from what you've just told me was
abhorrent and awful
and as bad as it was I want to flip the
other side of the coin and look at two
people who are losing their son they're
losing everything they've got
and the dog the father of these two
little girls that they love
and they start laughing their choice of
how to cope was to lash out okay now I'm
not saying you have to be in a
relationship with him in fact it sounds
like that's not a good idea
but I want to know if you have given
them notice
as to how you feel because if you don't
and by the way you giving notice to how
you feel
would have got your 14 year old self's
head knocked off
so your body knows do not tell people
how you feel you shut up you be quiet
about it and let them go about their day
because that's the safest way forward
except you can't keep going forward like
that anymore not with your two little
girls Fair yeah
totally fair so they have a right to
know
I think
go ahead
um I feel like I have
said
things like I've actually been said like
well we don't really need a relationship
between us like but I will never keep my
kids away from you like you'll always be
their grandparents and they're like but
we love you we want you to be in our
lives
and so
okay that's the part that's hard is
because I do know that they in their own
way love me and so I don't want to like
you know crush them but also I don't
know how to have a relationship with
them
because of how
things have gone in the past and just
how they are
as individuals they don't necessarily
take
other people being strong-willed very
well
and I
am just I really want to honor them and
their relationship with their
grandchildren and who they are uh no you
don't no you don't you want to avoid
conflict you want to avoid a fight I do
you don't want to honor them you want
them to be able to see their grandkids
and have no issues
and they have created they've created
issues
yeah and you've got issues the deal is
can we have our issues together
yeah so at some point like an offhanded
well like we're like we don't have to
have a relationship but I'll never keep
the girls from you
like at a left field a little bit that's
kind of like I don't know it's not
grenade throwing it's like throwing a
rock at a tank like did somebody just
throw a rock at us that's kind of like
that and then you went back and told
your friends I I'm leaving I went after
that tank like I mean kind of right so
foreign
here's the thing
you want to not hurt anybody's feelings
you want to not get in a fight
you also are tired of being controlled
by other people
you're tired of not being able to move
on and live your life
and you're tired of having your feelings
not count
and you can't pick
you can't have it all you gotta choose
and for your sake and for the sake of
those two little girls that are watching
their mom for how to deal with the worst
possible thing that could happen
for watching their two little girls
watching their mom
teach them about
your needs deserve to be heard they have
you have a right to say them out loud
and here's how you do that with dignity
and respect and boundaries are critical
all three of you deserve
to not live under the perceived tyranny
of a moment a grandma and a Granddad
that's just going to show up at your
house in some random Wednesday and stay
for a week
or that if you haven't had the
conversation yet about how you treated
me while my husband was dying
um and you all haven't worked through
that then man like you deserve more than
that
and here's so here's how I would do it I
don't like conflict either I don't love
it I don't run from it and I'll have it
I don't love it
um I think the first step always is to
write things down
here's what you actually did and said
and here's what I felt
and if you can mail that in a
handwritten letter not an email bomb but
a handwritten letter
or if you say hey I've been thinking
about what this is going to look like
long term
and long term who knows right you might
get remarried you might move to the
States you might move to Ireland who
knows
so we're going to do this a year at a
time
but for the next year here's what I need
or here not even so much what I need
here's what we're gonna do
you can see the girls on this date and
on this date
it's going to be great you all are free
to move your schedules around but this
is when this is going to happen
and
um
because we are healing as a family we're
not going to have any surprise show UPS
and expect them to try you on it
them just show up hey they're welcome
too you're not staying here and let me
tell you something if you lay out it out
clear not little passing rocks thrown at
a tank if you lay it out clear
in
Christmas
we're gonna come see you guys for three
days
and we're going to stay at a hotel and
the girls can spend the night at your
house once or twice
and we're gonna see you on spring break
those are the two times over the course
of the next year
um if you lay it out that clearly and
they show up and you don't let them stay
we drove seven hours well you drove
seven hours I'm sorry but we're heading
out to an event right now
you will you will walk six inches taller
okay so I'm going to give you the line
I've used it before on this show I don't
even remember where I got it from maybe
brene brown maybe I still perel I want
you to always As you move forward choose
guilt over resentment
okay
I want you to say no and feel really
guilty about saying no
then have them show up to your house
unannounced or with two days notice
which is a total power move
or you got to see who they what they
really think about you and the chips
were down
and now they're being all sweet and nice
to you because you are the pathway to
those grandkids and they're playing a
long game until those girls turn 18 and
they then they're gonna swoop in and
save the day and blah blah blah blah
blah no way no way
we're gonna choose guilt I'm gonna say
no no thank you oh I see I drove seven
hours to show up here and it's the
middle of winter it's negative a million
degrees here in uh
Canada sorry
but tonight's not a good night
um I told you I remember when I told you
very specifically when we were gonna
have people here
um now's not that time and you're going
to feel guilty as bloody hell you'll
feel so guilty but if you let them come
stay and they come again the next time
and they come again the next time
and then when they're 16 they're going
to send you a car for the girls even
though you've got a very clear financial
plan for them and I think there's just
going to be a power move after power
you're going to resent yourself
you're gonna start to resent those
little girls and you're especially going
to resent them
don't do that don't choose resentment
choose relationship and choose guilt
choose boundaries
okay
this is a skill you have to practice
because boundaries got you hurt as a kid
and you had really strong boundaries
around that man you loved and he died
and so your body has equated boundaries
with no no no no no no no no no
so you're gonna have to practice I'd get
a friend that you trust and you love and
you'll sit down and do boundaries
together help you write the letter
together
[Music]
exhale
send that letter
make the phone call make the visit and
say hey these are my girls this is my
life and this is how we're going to do
this moving forward and they get to
choose to be adults
and opt-in to your world because that's
really the only choice they've got
I'm proud of you Joe we'll be right back
hey deloney here and I've got a word
from our sponsor from betterhelp I've
been on the giving and receiving end of
therapy for years when I was spinning
out like a decade ago with wild anxiety
I had a moment that light bulb moment
that I knew I had to do something
different I knew I had to change
something probably a lot of some things
right but I found myself without the
tools for taking the next step
and when you're facing problems or
challenges in life it's way too easy to
get stuck in that anxious spiral of Doom
I've been there but when you learn how
to stop that cycle and start taking
ownership of your life that's when
you're free
and that's what therapy can help you do
it gives you the tools you need to do
the problem solving in your own life and
that's why I love better help better
help is online therapy that offers video
phone and even live chat sessions with
your therapist it's more affordable than
in-person therapy plus you can be
matched with a therapist in under 48
hours if you're ready to get the tools
that you need to deal with the
curveballs life's thrown at you therapy
can help visit betterhelp.com deloni to
get 10 off your first month that's
betterhelp.com deloney
all right we're back let's go to Patrick
in Jeffersonville moving on up what's up
Patrick
good morning Dr John how are you
excellent what's up
um I came to a bit of a
estimation that I'm starting to lose my
five-year-old son a little bit and I'm
trying to figure out how I can do a
course correction before it gets too
late and you know it's just completely
broken between us
what's what is helping you arrive at
that conclusion
um a little bit of the backstory where I
think it all started um starting in 2019
till just a couple weeks ago I was in
you know kind of an off again on again
Affair and during that time
that I would have communication with the
affair partner
you know I would throw everything to the
wind I would even kind of push him back
and I are you married after like yeah
so you had a three-year affair
how long have you been married
uh for gonna be seven years okay so for
three of the seven years you were
cheating on your wife
yeah okay and three of his five years
this little boy's five years
yeah and my guess is before you start
having an affair your marriage kind of
sucked then too right
yeah I mean we wasn't in the best of
places
so your marriage kind of sucked too
right
yeah yeah okay so the kid was born into
a house of Chaos
and or a house of tension let me put it
that way
and then you did something to relieve
your attention you didn't like who you
were becoming in this relationship and
you found somebody else for three years
did your wife know about this affair
uh not in the beginning that's uh when
it first started it took a couple of
months before it was exposed to her
and then she was just dope with it
happening for two more years
no that's that's another issue that
we've we've been having and he's been
wrapped up in what's that issue
uh me not me not being faithful and not
coming to her with the issues that I was
having and instead seeking out this
other person
okay let me let me back that thing up
and okay let me try to get this all the
way
in
so you get married a couple years in you
meet somebody else or you already knew
somebody else
you have an affair for a few
is that right go ahead yeah you have an
affair for a few months
your wife finds out
she either bust you or you told her
and then you get it all out she decides
to stay with you
and then you decide to keep having this
affair in secret for two and a half more
years
and she would find out every once in a
while or something like that
yeah there would be you know just
flip UPS on my part to where I'd get
careless and she would see the message
on my phone or um bro what's the matter
with you dude what do you mean you got
characters
I I was I'd say that's what I'm trying
to wear I've got a another
personal therapist that I speak with and
I'm trying to work that out to
um because I've you know to myself I've
been living a giant life for the last
three years and
dude you've been living yeah you've been
living alive for way longer than three
years
Fair yeah but I think that's fair yeah
Fair
you didn't screw up or slip up
I mean I guess you did if you're like
talking to a group of dudes who cheat on
their wives you're like oh I screwed up
I got busted
man and she stuck with you through all
of this
yeah I mean she she's a sweetheart she
is no she's a doormat
she is not a sweetheart that's how I
treated her and she is a doormat who is
in desperate need of being able to look
in the mirror and say I'm worth way the
hell more than this
and here's the deal I get dude I get it
I get the screw up I get the weekend
like oh my gosh I get the
you spend a lot of time with somebody
you work with and they end up becoming
your best friend I get all of that
three just Thumb in your nose at your
wife's face for three years man that's
tough
just yeah guy to guy that's tough man
because that's just been that's just
pissing on your wife dude that's just
not cool
and it's been tearing at me for you know
that long and even knowing that I I knew
it was wrong and that I shouldn't be
doing it there was just that you know
that Euphoria the high of when
I would have that connection with the
other person and then you would come
down on the other side and she's like my
goodness this was not worth it we need
to stop
bro you're you're not there yet man
you're not there yet
so yes if your kid is anxious if your
kid is struggling with hyperactivity if
your kid is struggling with Focus one
thousand percent yes he's right where he
should be there's not a a one damn thing
wrong with him
because he is living in a house of lies
and he's living in a house of
disconnection and he's living in a with
a mom
who is desperately hanging on to
somebody who thinks about it as much of
her as he does
the dog crap he picks up in the backyard
and he's living with a dad who's a
habitual liar
and that little boy is anchored into
connection I mean to he's just anchored
into he's untethered he's a kite in the
Wind
and there's no string
and I agree with that and I see that
from him because like you said whenever
you know we try to talk uh his mom and I
it's you know he starts acting crazy not
crazy as in like lunatic but jumping on
the couch with button in or trying to
instill our attention back to him
kind of like he's the mediator kind of
de-escalate the situation because he's
been the mediator trying to de-escalate
the situation for five freaking years
Fair
yeah yeah he's just doing his job that's
the job y'all gave him because no one
else is being an adult in that house
are you still having an affair now
no no I I came totally clean with her
the last week uh our second last week of
September
you know I laid everything that was
going on out there
and how long has it been since you've
been with this other person
the first week of September was the last
time I
so for those of you we record these
several weeks ahead so it's been about a
month
right
yeah yeah
you're not done having an affair Yet
brother
because that high feeling is every bit
as
foreign
it's about you feeling alive dude and
you have a wife and a kid and it's easy
to get dead-eyed real fast in life to
get real boring real fast and you don't
like who you become when you're
dead-eyed and bored
and this other person makes you feel
alive because she doesn't have to live
with you and you don't have to live with
her and you can play Fantasy for two and
a half hours
and that's why I'm trying to get more
intentional with it in the beginning you
don't try to get intention with this you
never freaking talk to her again ever
ever you delete her from everything you
throw your phone in the trash in the
toilet
that's basically what I did I I'm off
social media my in the beginning I
wouldn't give my wife my phone she has
complete and total access to my phone I
have the accounts but she has the
passwords I don't log into the app
they're not on my phone for me to log
into them
and I'm I'm taking more of the steps
forward that I didn't take in the
beginning to where I was more bullish
and stubborn and
this is about you saying I'm giving up
my power because you've got power over
her
and it feels good to have power over
somebody finally in your life
and it's about you taking a knee so good
for you man you've done you've given up
your cell phone passcodes cool
I've talked to too many guys who cheated
on their wives
and when they're ready to stop cheating
there is a totally different way that
they come across as a totally different
ethos
I don't hear it on you it may be if you
and I were hanging out man I don't want
to I don't want to judge you just by the
tone of your voice Max I can't even see
you
um
but this isn't something you just kind
of figure out you just kind of working
on it it is scorched Earth man
this is falling down on your face in
front of your wife and saying I failed
you
oh and not only that I failed you I
broke your heart and then I took your
heart and I just
rubbed it in the dirt and stomped on it
because she were too much of a chump to
leave me
and here's the thing with here comes to
your son dude you can't say anything
your words simply do not matter to him
one thing will matter to him and that is
action
okay he is watching everything you do
and if you walk into that home and
you're an agent of Peace the house gets
more warm when you show up
and you walk right past him or his arms
are outstretched and you walk right past
him
and you go grab his mother gently by the
face and you look her in the eyes and
say I love you and every day of the rest
of my life is dedicated to meeting your
needs
I will find my aliveness
through reinvigorating our love
and then you hug her for 15 to 30
seconds every day before you even
acknowledge that kid
then over time 60 90 120 days a year
later
when he sees you all together his body
will begin to say that's right not
that's War which is what his body says
now
okay and then if you commit to never
taking your cell phone out of your car
when you get home
so that you are fully present and by the
way
if you're like me it's awkward I don't
know what to do man when I'm just
sitting there with two little kids and
my wife I don't know what to do my body
starts rattling a little bit so I gotta
have a set of practices
sometimes I have to change my
environment I got to go get on the floor
and play with my kids I got a wrestling
mat upstairs I go wrestle with my kids I
got two
do a puzzle that I've done a hundred
thousand times I gotta do it again
right being a parent sometimes is super
boring
and my life isn't just about me being
entertained
it's about being with not over with
and every day of your life you got to
wake up and address your wife in the in
public in your living room or in your
kitchen and say how can I best love you
today what does today look like for us
and she might say get out go to work and
you'll go great I'm gonna have a great
day at work
and she might say I just need you to sit
by me not say anything can we just have
coffee and you say no words and you'll
say yep absolutely
do you see what I'm getting at
yeah that's why I don't think you're
here I don't think you're there yet
because you're talking about
completely cashing in your entire Mo
which is I know something you don't know
I've got power over you and I can do
whatever the hell I want whenever I want
because you ain't going nowhere
and that's something that I've been
working with with my therapist and
something that I've I don't like about
myself and I don't I can't stand I mean
when I I hold on to that and it's I know
that you know these last three years
that she hasn't went anywhere so I've
been able to just you know do whatever I
want I had the keys to the car and I was
driving it
and I don't I don't want to live like
that I don't want to treat my wife that
way I don't want to raise my children in
that type of environment I want to be
the best need that I can be for them and
for her
so it's not total chaos and it's not
tension and stressful to where we're
bickering and we're arguing or just not
talking like we're roommates and
like we're still madly in love like we
were when we were teenagers
you're not hey you're not going to be
madly in love like you were when you
were teenagers
you're not
the sex in your marriage at year 10 will
be infinitely better than it was Year
One
and the sex in your marriage in your 15
and 20 will be infinitely better than it
was in Year One
what you don't have is perspective on
that yet
madly in love like ah I'm gonna blow off
class and I'm gonna skip school and I'm
gonna go put a bunch of crap on the
credit card to that goes away
and then you build something infinitely
more structurally sound
but if you keep chasing madly in love
dude your marriage is going to end up in
Ash and you're gonna burn those kids to
the ground
you have to chase something bigger than
that
something deeper than that
and that my friend is love
and I'll I'll I would be willing to bet
you don't even know what that looks like
you'd never see it your parents didn't
show you your old man didn't show you
and I I honor that dude it's a set of
skills that you don't I'm asking you to
mow a yard and you've never seen a lawn
mower you've never seen grass okay
that your mission is to figure that out
what love looks like
as the great poet Stephen Connell says
love is a promise that comes what comes
I will be right here
and you've got to learn that
and the all of your figuring out
language dude enough with that you do
need to figure out some skills no
question I'm glad you're working with a
counselor you do need to figure out at
some point where you learned this that
people are worth being treated that way
but all this I'm trying to learn it no
never raise your voice again in your
home
whenever you start to get into an
argument with your wife put both hands
up and stop it and say hey hey
I love you too much to continue in down
this road and we've been down this road
and we know where it leads so I'm not
gonna fight you let's Circle back in 30
minutes okay
whenever she says hey you make me feel
like you don't butt in with your yeah uh
you you say I'm so sorry
how can I help make this right
and you can say whatever you want to to
that little boy
if you want him back treat his mom right
you want him back
be present with him you want him back
tell the truth you want him back invite
him into a life of Peace not a life of
War
voluntarily give your attention to him
don't make him work for it
hug him for 30 seconds every day of his
life and put your hands on his face kiss
him on the forehead if they'll allowed
kiss him on the face on the cheeks on
the neck tell him that you love him
[Music]
with your actions
got a long way to go my brother
I'm optimistic for you man you got real
real real lucky with who you married
time for you to step up and do your part
we'll be right back
hey deloney here one of the things I
love about my job is answering the tough
questions people have when they call
into the show your stories are
incredible in each person's situation is
unique and for years people from all
over the world have been asking if I do
private counseling or private coaching
sessions for them or for their spouse
and as much as I'd love to I can't
realistically do one-on-one coaching
sessions with every single person it's
just not possible but that's exactly why
I wrote my new book own your past change
your future within the pages of this
book is exactly what I would say if you
and I were sitting down together at a
table looking for the next right move
for you to make in your relationships or
to help you live a more whole and
peaceful life as you read through each
section of this book I will show you how
to look and own the roads from your past
and head to the New Roads of a well life
moving forward go to John deloney.com to
get your copy today that's own your past
change your future at John deloney.com
all right we are back and my heart rate
is still up
hey all of us grew up in our
relationships 100 of us all of us do all
of us have conversations with people we
probably shouldn't have we think things
we shouldn't have we say things we
shouldn't do we do things we shouldn't
do it happens it happens it happens it
happens and I'll sit with everybody in
that fire all day long
but at some point we've got to own up
and take responsibility and not take the
person we love and take their hurt
hurting heart that we hurt
and grind it into dust
over one year two years three years
and if you're keeping secrets from your
spouse if you've got stuff you got to
say say it say it
conflict deferred as conflict Amplified
man say it
because the hiding has a cost
and if you screwed up and you and your
husband are working through it you and
your wife are working through it my wife
and I have worked through multiple
things over 20 years
the goal of working through it isn't to
be right and to be right and to be right
the goal of working through it is to say
how can we come together how can we grow
into something new
and what I promise you is all the
research continues to say a marriage
that chooses good stuff
a good marriage of two people who love
each other
and commit to each other and keep coming
back and keep coming back is the highest
marker of longevity
and a bad marriage a marriage of War
destruction and chaos and tension and
anxiety
is one of the surest signs of early
physiological dysfunction
choose if you're married choose to do
right if you're married choose to have a
great marriage why would you choose
anything else both of you
choose to have a good life man choose a
good life
all right as we wrap up today's show
can't get over there I still can't get
over this show
I'm really struggling because turnstile
blew my mind this year and the killers
were so they were 10 times better than I
thought they were gonna be I thought
they were gonna be pretty good
and then during the show they had a new
song I'd never heard it before it's
their new single song's called boy
and I remember it from the show if that
tells you how good it is song goes like
this just give yourself some time head
down wrong fit big deal that's just
growing up untouched 16 don't overthink
it boy white arrows will break
the Black Knight don't overthinkable
and when you're out on the ledge please
come down boy there's a place that
exists just give it some time drawn
arrows unseen will fly Heat Wave slow
lane a small town only diesels dance
these streets weren't meant to house jet
fueled engine dreams white arrows Will
Blast the Black Knight
don't overthink it boy don't overthink
it we'll see you soon
[Music]